[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome vice
president amir google cloud sebastian
murat morning everyone welcome welcome
to Google next Amsterdam 2017 we are
super excited very thrilled to have all
of you here we have put a lot of energy
a lot of passion to organize this day
it's really a very important day so
welcome to this nice little charming
Dutch house it's kind of a cool place
with full of solar reports to renovate
this place and to build this place for
you I was told that this used to be a
ship manufacturing so a factory which
was built in 1920 and from 1922 1924
they have doubled the production of
shipyards so they moved from downtown to
this place so it's a really cool place
so welcome super excited to host this
day it's you know it's a great event for
us it's a bit of a world tour we have
done during the past few weeks we
started in San Francisco I think it was
in something like April May and at that
time we have made more than 100 product
customer and partner announcements so a
lot of great things that we've been
announcing and today is gonna be also
very cool because we're probably going
to make additional few announcements so
it's a great opportunity I think most of
the audience today is coming from a
development community so it's a great
opportunity for us to connect our
engineers with the developer community
but today is going to be a really a
great opportunity also to hear from our
customers how they are turning this
amazing new technologies into very
innovative ideas that are we changing
the weather and our business so another
great stuff customer stories a lot of
demonstration and a lot of discussions
around what is really important to
consider when you're starting this
journey into the cloud because this is
definitely a journey so I want to spend
few minutes on few things first of all
for a lot of you it's a bit of a
discovery the question mark is what is
this Google cloud business for others
you're gonna deep dive into some part of
the story and so part of the technology
so why don't we start first of all about
Google cloud if you think about Google
cloud Google cloud is pretty much the
extension of everything we have been
doing at Google since we created the
company I was not there in 1998 at an
immense privilege actually to start this
business in Europe the Google cloud
business six seven years ago but when
you think about 1998 when Larry and
Sergey created the company their vision
and a mission which is very much in play
today it's really to organize the world
information and to make it accessible
and useful for everyone in her on earth
and think about the enterprise space we
are running we are part of great
companies whether you're a digital
natives or you're an enterprise company
and it's exactly the same think about it
it's really about data we are just
managing swimming into the data whether
it's a customer data or its industrial
data and what we really care at Google
is really to turn this data into a
comprehensive business models into
innovation so that you can not only
change the way you run your business but
more importantly really build a
competitive advantage to build what's
next and this is why this event is
called next we really care about what is
going to be next which products services
you're going to create for your
customers and again to be more
competitive and at the end of the day
actually at Google we realize that it
was just pretty much what we were doing
so as I said since the being of a story
but this is the way we have built our
own company and this is the way we have
grown our company you know if
think about it Google cloud is really
enterprise business and its really built
on three or four very important pillars
one is the data center and
infrastructure we have been building the
other one is the amazing network that we
have built around the globe actually to
be able to to transfer this data and to
process this data
the other one is mobility if you had to
think about a third pillar and the last
one
and the last one is the one we are
talking about pretty much everywhere
which is machine learning and artificial
intelligence which is being baked in
everything we are doing right now so
think about the platform at the end of
the day our mission is really to deliver
a highly scalable open and secure
platform to build your business if you
are digital natives or to build what's
next if you are an enterprise company
and we've got few layers and this is
very important actually because this is
really how we're gonna run this day
together the first one which is super
important is infrastructure I mean
nothing would have been I would have
been happen without the infrastructure
that we have been building at Google all
these data centers that we have been
building at that we are expanding in
across all the differential graph ease
and the good thing if you think about
the Netherland and the Benelux we have
one of the largest infrastructure and
data center around the world in this
region so which is really great
this is infrastructure that we have been
narrated and this is infrastructure that
is hosting probably you heard about that
more than seven services that are being
used by more than billion users and
that's super important I mean there is
no way you're going to be able to manage
in your enterprise the volume of data
that is right now floating into your
company without the capacity to the
super capacity actually to host this
data so this is also and that you
probably don't know actually all if you
think about our Google cloud customer I
mean they are themselves servicing more
than a billion users within their
community this is really the
infrastructure that is hosting our
amazing products around the tonality
and around machine-learning so this is
important the other thing which is very
important is what we are providing to
the developer community and a lot of
things are going to be demonstrated
today whether it's all this matter
appear api's that you can find the
translation API the video API is the
vision API all this set of API run
natural language there are here are
totally open and usable or this amazing
actually
products around continent management or
kubernetes and again all this multi PS
so we are really investing or for the
developer community which is extremely
important actually to build again your
next applications the other thing that
we care a lot about and I know that
we've got a lot of companies in the room
that is being at that are using these
products its productivity so we not only
want to deliver the right technology to
build your next application but you we
really want actually to help you
changing the way you're working within
your company by Bearer engaging your
employees through some live
collaboration processes you know I had a
chance to again join this company six
seven years ago and I don't remember the
last time I really attach a file in an
email this is totally over I mean it's
really about live collaboration it's
about engaging people together and we
will have a specific session on that
which is totally changing actually the
way people are working and really
implanting implementing a new culture
within your company the other thing
we'll really care a lot about and that
you probably heard and you will hear
more and more it's all about our mobile
strategy and whether it's Android of
course which is by far the most used
operating system in the environment in
the mobile environment now we're getting
into the enterprise space or the Chrome
OS which is probably the more secure and
shareable an easy operating system to
access all of this information there are
a lot of studies right now stating that
by 2018 25% of the fortune 500 companies
will start using Chrome OS as an
operating system to sexually work into
their
and their environment so this is the
platform this open platform that we are
right now delivering to the marketplace
so what happens in 2017 I mean we all
know that the cloud is the thing that we
need to embrace and to adapt we all know
that every single business every single
industries is being disrupted I have
again the privilege to meet a lot of
executives I used to live in in America
where we were Austin a lot of executive
in our existing briefing centers and
every single executive coming from any
kind of industries are telling us that
their industry is being disrupted and
they really want to partner with us to
figure out how they can be leading this
next generation and this next business
within their industry so at the same
time the market is moving extremely fast
we are also investing a lot in this
business and you know to be very candid
actually three to two three four years
ago we were having question about how
serious Google was with this business
and for the past 24 to 36 months and I
hope you've seen that actually and we
would like to get your feedback so it's
very important to get that today we have
been investing in making this company
really an enterprise ready company by
releasing whether about our engineers
actually we're releasing 500 releases
during the next few years or by
launching these new great products and
we have dedicated sessions to discover
products like cloud machine learning or
like spanner but also by implementing
some technical resources and connecting
again our engineers to our companies so
this is super important there is another
thing which is extremely important and
you will have some sessions today it's
compliance policy and security at the
same time everybody is moving to the
cloud what we are seeing is highly
regulated industries and companies are
going to the cloud and especially in
Europe and in this country in particular
it is super important actually to spend
a lot of time efforts on compliance and
security the other thing that we are
investing a lot of time at Google cloud
is to making sure that not only we can
provide the best tools and processes
around machine
running which i think is definitely
where we are leading the game or
analytics or a big data and bigquery but
it's really about lifting and shifting
your on-premise world looks at workloads
into the cloud and we have dedicated
teams actually to help you migrating
this so we are here to solve business
issues which ever actually you can you
your belonging to so whether you're a
hospital or a banker or whether you are
running a store or you're building a
video game or you're running a media
company or you're making energy I think
we are seeing a lot a lot of companies
coming to us and adopting our business
so if you are for instance we've got a
lot of digital natives historically
companies in Europe very close to my
heart actually like Spotify or very
famous companies like eBay or snapchat
they literally built snapchat built its
business on Google cloud companies like
Spotify that I mentioned moved all their
workloads into Google cloud actually to
go to the next step and really provide a
much better business experience and and
and build actually competitive advantage
to be leading actually the market
they're operating into but you're seeing
on this ties a lot of very traditional
companies and this is where it's
fascinating actually to be part of their
journey on how we can really coach these
companies to move a success to
successfully to the cloud and
step-by-step I think one of the largest
company we've been working or we are
starting the journey with and probably
you had a chance to listen to Darrell
West the global CIO when he was in San
Francisco is that HSBC think about HSBC
it's probably they hold this Bank in the
world they have been in the business for
150 years and it's probably one of the
most conservative industry company in
the world I mean in the most a regulated
industry of course which is the banking
industry and it's fascinating to see
that a company that has been created 150
years ago
of course as generated a lot a lot of
data actually it's funny because it took
them 130 years to start measuring they
are they tie into terabytes and for the
past 20 years actually they have
generated
fifteen para bites and now they are
thinking about how they are going to
handle an additional five per bites just
for the next 12 months this is what we
are talking about it's really a tool
explosion so if you think about HSBC
again which is a very traditional
company they did everything right for
the past 20 years they started with
rational database and then they reach
the limits and they moved progressively
actually to the traditional data
warehousing that were available 15-20
years ago and they found that warehouses
started to be really expensive and
difficult to manage so what are they
done they moved to these big data
actually technologies with the duper and
they thought it's extremely challenging
because certainly they had actually to
learn about these technologies they are
to learn how to feed actually this
technology they add to a building for a
structure they are to maintain
infrastructure and it was extremely
challenging so what they've done
actually they started to figure out that
this is the data game and they didn't
want actually to turn a company into I
mean a computer of Google or any of our
computers actually did you just wanted
to run their business so they have
decided to select Google to start this
analytical journey this cloud journey so
they are moving the bank to the cloud
and they are moving the bank to the
cloud with Google so it's again a
journey we are just starting but it's
really fascinating and we are seeing
more and more of these cases right now
so I'd like to run on two things number
one I really want to thank all the
partners that are in the room you have
an amazing exhibition it's extremely
important for us you know if you won't
be an enterprise ready organization
which we are you need actually to create
this partner ecosystem so it's very
close to our hand to our hats all right
and not only I mean it's important to
onboard some technological partners but
also some resellers then also some
global system integrators that are going
to help you again migrating your
workloads and also building what's next
in your organization so spend some time
with these guys they have invested in
this event and they are ever actually to
tell you more about the value they can
bring to your organization at the end of
the day again what I said it's it's a
journey and very honestly and candidly
I mean it's really about you and and the
kind of discussions we are having with
our customers I mean our very
interesting because this is so new
this is so new for everyone how many
times actually we are sitting down with
our customers and they are just asking
us how should I get started how do how
do I do it what is really what do I need
actually
who should I recruit how can I find the
talents how can i what am I going to do
with my IT a current organization how
can I train these people how much is it
going to cost me
am I going to be again locked into a
kind of partnership or so-called
partnership with an IT company do I have
to rewrite my quota I mean all of these
questions are really questions that we
are trying to help you answering and
this is why I mean something that died
engrained decided very quickly when she
came on board two years ago they she is
our CEO she was the founder of VMware I
mean the I said we have probably the
best technology we can find right now in
the market but stop just bidding here
it's not only about technology it's
about the ability to build an enterprise
organization and connect our technical
people to making sure that we can help
you building this project so you will
see a lot of Googlers we call that
Googlers we are Googlers and in the in
the rumor you might see some what we
call customer success engineer that will
help you piloting and prototyping your
your application you're going to see a
lot of engineers also as I said earlier
on that will really help you to drive
the right technical conversations you
will see some dedicated architect that
are organized by industry we call them
the office of the CTO it's like we have
tens of cgu in the organization and are
here again to sit down with you and I'm
so proud and happy actually to have a
lot of them here today in the in the
room so connect with this CTO and also
professional services organization again
that will help you and help our partners
to implement and migrate your
application so this is what it is about
we are going to super excited to spend
the day too
we have a lot to share with you a lot of
private modes and customer stories and
without waiting I'm going to pass it
over to Julian blonde Shay who is going
to tell us about security privacy and
compliance Thank You Thea welcome Thank
You Sebastian I hope the audience will
cope with another 15 minutes of French
accent let's see if you can spot through
the day how many accents we have and
where we come from each and every one of
us my name is Julia Blanca I've been
working nine years with Google the last
four years engaged with these
engineering security and compliance
teams in California I recently relocated
back to Brussels and my role now is to
engage with regulators and large
prospects large customers to help answer
you know the detailed questions and
facilitate the communication between the
European markets and these engineering
teams so today millions of companies are
considering to move all or some of their
workloads to the cloud and they have
several reasons to do that one of the
reasons that you might not have expected
to be so prominent and to actually be
the first one a cloud provider talks
about is security and yet it is a widely
accepted fact today that large cloud
platforms offer a significant capability
to improve your security stance and
there are a number of reasons for that
that I want to go over in the next few
minutes when you want to assess the
capability of a security system there is
a well known framework that recommends
to look at the capability to anticipate
the capability to defend and the
capability to react when it comes to
anticipation large cloud platforms like
Google have a significant advantage you
know we as Sebastian was saying Google
is operating a
products with more than a billion users
actually Google photo just passed the
billion user mark a couple of weeks ago
so this would you know add one to this
list so you can imagine the amount of
information the amount of exposure the
amount of testing we get every single
day to know what is happening on the
cloud and I just want to highlight one
one of these platforms Google Android
today is two billion devices and Google
Android has a service called safety net
that you can google if you want and
safety net poles every single day four
hundred million Android devices to
gather the security information from the
devices and allows our teams to build a
close to real-time you know cartography
of the threat landscape so this gives
you an idea of the amount of information
and knowledge you can benefit from when
you operate on these on these platforms
going on to defense our infrastructure
teams had a great luxury 18 years ago
when they started to build these
platforms they could start they could
start sorry from a blank slate they did
not have to cope with generations of
legacy technology that is creating the
complexity that in one word really
summarizes the security challenge today
it is not to say that Google is not
complex right Google is two billion
lines of codes 20 to 30 thousand
engineers interacting daily on to two
billion lines of codes forty to fifty
thousand change requests per day on the
code so this complexity is is mastered
by automation intelligent automation not
to use the buzzword of machine learning
and artificial intelligence here but
these systems have allowed to tackle
successfully great security challenges
like spam for example and will allow to
tackle some of the big problems like
authentication and I will be elaborating
on this more this afternoon in the
security breakout so when regulators
today are talking about security by
design and this is becoming a very
important criteria these platforms and
Google as embedded security into the
system
but also intelligent intelligent
mechanisms that learn to adapt to the
evolving nature of these threats next I
want to talk about the level of control
that Google has managed to keep over the
entire technology stack because of the
size we operate at from the hardware to
the operating system you know all the
way up to the user interface Google has
kept a very high level of homogeneity as
developed and deployed its own
technology and kept this level of
homogeneity across the technology stack
this level of imagina T is what allows
us to identify threats or incidents
relatively faster and reacts relatively
faster because we have less you know
different solutions to bring and are
less dependent on external suppliers now
in this time where notification bridge
and the speed at which you can react and
notify your data privacy authorities you
know this kind of capabilities is going
to be critical and this is the kind of
strength that you really want to have on
your side then we should all be aware of
the importance of a global
infrastructure in this security game
today Google is 15 data centers across
located across the world four of them in
Europe Finland Ireland Belgium the
Netherlands two more coming before the
end of the year or very soon but most
importantly these data centers are
connected by our own proprietary fiber
and this network infrastructure allows
us also to deliver you very low latency
but most importantly when it comes to
security be much more in control of our
own destiny when it comes to transport
data from one continent to the other
more importantly this kind of global
infrastructure allows us to aim to
deliver the same level of security for
everybody you are not going to be to
receive more security if you're in
Durham
than if you're in China or in Pakistan
for that matter or in the u.s. so this
is the capability of these large
platforms and really the mission of the
Google security teams to deliver the
same level of security to everybody now
these security discussions can go on for
days you know with large prospects weeks
sometimes if we really dig into the
detail and answer all the question they
all end up to the same conclusions large
cloud platforms offer significant
improvement of what most companies can
deliver today but they all leave our
prospect with the same feeling that you
probably have at this right moment when
you realize that to benefit from that
to benefit from that security you need
to load your data onto a third party
infrastructure and this requires a leap
of faith this requires a level of
confidence that we cannot force onto you
all that we can do is be more
transparent share more information tell
you where our data centers are located
tell you who our subprocessors are show
you the dashboards public life of
availability of our systems to allow you
to build that confidence to come to sign
the contract when you sign the contract
this is when you really gain legal
control over how your data will be
managed and you will be looking for
clauses like scope of processing the
commitment that Google will not use your
data for any other purpose than deliver
you the service and you paid for the
commitment on intellectual property
portability the contractual commitment
that you can leave the infrastructure at
any given moment how we will react to a
third-party request to access your data
international jurisdiction you know will
be also added to these clothes the
commitment that will keep the security
certifications during that we have now
during the entire duration of the
agreement with you and finally the
capability that you have to verify that
we do what we say
through audits you know and the
capability to audit our our systems now
most of you and most of your
stakeholders that you
have to go out and convince we'll be
wondering how this can work within the
legal framework in Europe and notably
with the arrival of the GDP our you know
this new regulation that is going to
increase dramatically the power of the
data privacy authorities to invest to
make sure that we all do what we should
do when it comes to handling data that
the deadline is coming close and that is
why we have announced several weeks ago
already our firm commitment for Google
cloud you know Google cloud platform and
G suite will comply with the
expectations of the GD P R and you will
be receiving in the coming weeks and
month you know new legal terms that
really confirm that you have these
commitments that will allow will allow
you to remain compliant with the
European regulation the G GD P R is very
specific on one topic which is
international data transfers an article
46 of the GD P R is what you want to
Google if you want to have the legal
text I encourage you to do that it is
actually for once a very easy simple
Clause article to read article 46
specifies very clearly that a data
controller which is you or data Prince
processor which is us may only export
European data outside of Europe if
adequate safety measures are in place
and that is why back in January we had
our adequate safety measures you know as
described in our standard model and
standard contractual clauses added to
our contract we had them verified and
approved by the European institutions
that clearly means that under the GD P R
you will not be required to keep data
only in Europe when you're using a
Google cloud platform you may do so you
may not do so you may use the platform
as you wish
if you have these contract clauses now
very clearly when you engage into the
cloud you understand that there is a
significant portion of the compliance
and security demands of the regulators
that are
going to be managed by Google and this
portion will vary depending if you
implement software as a service platform
as a service of in infrastructure as a
service but even in the green area where
regulators and your customers will be
expecting you to raise your game you
know and deliver to the new level of
expectations of the European regulator
Google technology can help you achieve
these goals and I just want to tease you
with a couple of the building blocks
that are available and we can discuss
further during the day the strong
authentication ranks very high on the
list of regulators today and the list of
hackers today when it comes to assess
your capability to defend rolling out
these security keys you know that are a
two-step authentication factor hardware
token that we have rolled out at Google
several years ago can significantly
improve your capability enforcing their
usage is also a good idea just talking
about authentication another big topic
is anonymization the regulator requires
you now to anonymize and encrypt the
data when using google cloud technology
your data is encrypted by default this
is a significant differentiator versus
other platforms we will manage the
encryption for you if you decide you may
manage your own keys you may manage the
keys themselves yourself sorry or you
may bring your own encryption keys to
remain completely in control of your
data finally in the spirit of keen
warden Madden I want to introduce Peter
who will demonstrate the capability of
the data loss prevention API which will
allow you to scan your own data to
identify you know personal information
or sensitive data sometimes even
possibly in real time in your systems
and that can greatly help you in your
journey towards the gdpr Peter thank you
really am
I want to show you a short demo of an
enterprise application that can be used
in a customer service organization so
this is a chat application and in this
scenario we've been chatting with Angela
solving her issue now typically in such
as jet you would ask for some personal
information to make sure you look up her
history see if she had other issues
before and that sort of stuff so we
asked for her name and her contact
number and she did provide that but in
the meantime she gave us so much more
she gave her insurance number and she
even uploaded a picture of her passport
now that's probably not the smartest
thing to do but it gives us a problem
right because if we want to store the
content of this chat which is commonly
done we have a problem because it
contains personal identifiable
information so we can't use it for
auditing we can't use it for analysis we
can't use it for training purposes and
so forth so what the DLP API provides it
provides a mechanism to take the content
of this chat run it through the API and
provide a redacted version of this
content or all the personal information
has been removed so let me respond to
Angela thanking her and and the chat so
now all the content is running through
the API and what you will notice here is
that all the information that is
personal has been redacted we see that
her name was taken out we see that a
phone number has been removed insurance
number we even went into the picture to
take out her face and remove any
sensitive content from the picture as
well and to show you that this is life I
have a small document scanner set up
here I have a sample of a Dutch Passport
it's fake so you don't need to take
pictures I can put it under the scanner
click on the capture image and it will
run through the API and it will
correctly identify the burka sheriff's
number and it will take out the face
so that's an example how you can apply
the data loss prevention API in your
organization in an enterprise
application back to you Julia
thank you Peter very impressive when you
speak to your risk managers in your
organization and you hear how worried
they are about every single one of us
organizing the birthday parties of our
children through our corporate emails
and capturing thereby the identity of
all these children of all their parents
and then you know having the regulator
comes in two years and asking why did
you keep that information this is the
kind of technology that will help your
risk managers okay so I do not want to
leave you without a parting thought
often faced with at the end of these
discussions you know you're faced with
executives that have to decide whether
they go to the cloud or not go to the
cloud very confusing decision and I
since a few weeks recommend now to
divide the decision process into four
different steps the first is to make a
purely technical risk assessment where
is your data going to be safer from a
purely technical point of view and I'm
quite confident very confident actually
that this process will lead to the
direction we talked about in the last
few minutes then engage into a legal
assessment what does the law really
require and as we've discussed about the
gdpr
it will unify the legal landscape in
Europe it has very clear expectations
the discussions the legal discussions
are actually getting much easier by the
month then make a political assessments
there are a number of countries today
that are passing laws to keep the data
in country and you need to be sure that
your cloud provider can cope with these
demands these countries you know them
two years ago Russia six months ago
China and our teams are very paying a
lot of attention to a couple of other
countries in the center parts of the
world you know the Middle East at the
moment where these these
could also take place you get the
picture
data location laws are very rarely meant
to improve the privacy of the data
nevertheless you need to remain
operational in these countries can your
cloud provider guarantee the security of
the data while at the same time
satisfying the expectations of these
regulators important assessment finally
the cultural assessments you will be you
might be faced with reactions like I see
a lot in France for example I'm a French
company I want my data to remain in
France or you have unions that have
expectations for the data remain in
France or your data is you know deemed
national treasure very fine these are
very good reasons why you might not be
able to get the data outside but make
sure that when you go through your
decision process
you clearly dis make a distinction
between these four different levels and
prioritize them accordingly in your
decision this is the last thing I want
to say before introducing you to Tino
who will tell you more about machine
learning and our big data capabilities
Tino thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Julian no French accent I'm
sorry well I am absolutely ecstatic to
be here I absolutely love Amsterdam the
energy the the sophistication the the
technical talent here is just
astonishing and on a personal level
Amsterdam is one of my favorite places
in the whole world there's just such a
tremendous place to be here and I I'm
just I'm just beyond ecstatic here so
Julian did a fantastic job telling you
how Google can protect your organization
from a security point of view I'd like
to talk about a little bit of a
different angle and that's basically
data
how can an organization embrace data
because the reality of today's world
today's environment is that you must be
a data company in order to succeed so
you must have an innovation partner that
can help you manage your data and get
the most value out of the data provide
analytics help you understand your
customers and help interact with the
world through a machine learning and
artificial intelligence so but the
reality of today's technical environment
again is that infrastructure is very
complex your engineers are tasked with a
number of day-to-day engagements that
you know there's a whole lot of things
that you must do every single day in
order to just keep the lights on and
these things are relatively low value
you can consider them tinkering with
infrastructure and they're the one
little bit that really provides value to
organization it can be very very small
relatively small so what if you could
flip that equation on its head so Google
cloud platform provides our large number
of services they're very high level
fully managed services but abstract away
a lot of complexity of managing your own
the infrastructure and your own services
a very very high level of abstraction
very very high level of automation that
allows your engineers to focus on what's
really important to your organization
and try to provide the value right which
accelerates your pace of innovation
allows you to iterate allows you to
delight your customers allows you to
focus on your customers and I'm
delighted to present George here from
Phillips who is going to talk about how
Phillips has implemented Google cloud
platform and solve their issues when
implementing the Phillips hue platform
George Thank You Tina
it's a great pleasure to be here today
to tell you about my product Phillips
hue and how we're using the Google cloud
platform to connect lighting to the
Internet and hopefully change it for
everyone forever philips Lighting is the
world's largest lighting company and I'm
pretty confident when I say that every
single person in this room has
experienced at least one of our products
whether it's with regular lighting you
have in your own homes lighting you
walked under in street lamps on the way
here or the lighting in one of the
thousands of monuments like the
Rijksmuseum here in Amsterdam that we
liked one of the key drivers of my
company is transforming the role of
lighting by making it more connected we
believe that we can leverage the fact
that lighting is everywhere ubiquitously
around us to make the world easier to
personalise easier to monitor easier to
manage
and easier to control my father Philips
hue is our answer to that in the
consumer space it's one of the most
popular smartphone products in the world
and what we really believe is that we
can totally transform the role that
lighting plays in your home we believe
that lighting can be an alternative to
having a guard dog by making it seem
like you're at home when you're away on
vacation we believe that lighting could
be an alternative to your morning cup of
coffee
by leveraging the physiological response
our body has two different shades of
white light we believe that lighting is
an alternative to painting your home and
decorating by being able to change the
look and feel of a space multiple times
a day by changing the brightness and
color of your lights we even believe
that lighting could be an alternative to
a surround sound system by extending the
experience of the screen into your room
with synchronized light scripts and we
can do all of this while making your
home more convenient and comfortable now
we started with philips hue back in 2012
and from the very beginning we knew we
needed to have a cloud back-end we
needed to be able to keep our products
up to date in the field we needed to be
able to understand and learn from how
people were using the system to make it
better over time we needed to give the
ability for consumers to control their
lights when they weren't at home so that
they could have the lights automatically
be on when they arrived home and be able
to check that they hadn't left things on
when they were away and we also knew we
wanted to connect our lighting to react
to other cloud services like if this
then that so that all of your lights in
your home can flash red when your
favorite sports team scores all of these
told us we needed a cloud platform but
we also had some unusual requirements
the way we actually serve this cloud
service towards our customers is we
bundle it for free in the initial
purchase price of the product what that
means is we actually have to bundle the
lifetime cost of serving that customer
into that initial purchase price is part
of the bill of material of our product
so it's absolutely crucial for us in
order to keep the product affordable for
consumers that the incremental cost of
serving a new home is kept as low as
possible
in that way we're able to actually make
the purchase price of the product
cheaper we also needed to make sure that
we could scale this product in a very
cost-effective way we didn't know when
we started that this product would be
hugely successful or would take slower
to ramp up and because we started as an
internal startup we didn't want to be
lumbered with a huge operational
overhead keeping this thing running but
equally if it did take up very fast
which luckily it did we need to be able
to keep up with scaling Google cloud
solved this for us and we're constantly
pleasantly surprised as the market keeps
growing faster and faster they were able
to keep up with scaling in a very smooth
way another thing which has become
increasingly important is we care about
latency we've been trained the last
hundred years of having lighting in our
homes that when you press a button the
light turns on immediately why should it
be any different if you have internet
connected lighter so we put a lot of
energy into optimizing the total latency
from when you do an action which goes
via the cloud to the lights reacting
becoming even more important with voice
platforms in our home we have a very
broad partnership with Google we use a
wide variety of different Google cloud
products but we also work very closely
with the Android ecosystem and with the
smart home products in the Google things
like nest and Google assistant so let's
have a quick look at what it takes to
actually turn on a light bulb in 2017
let's start with let's start with a
command from something like Google
assistant so someone in their home they
get out their phone and they say ok
Google turn off my lights what happens
that command goes up to the Google
infrastructure does the voice
recognition generates the command and it
comes with a client request towards our
API the API is initially managed by
Apogee where we're handling that the
command is properly authenticated and
within the quotas of its application
that's then passed over towards a
service that runs in Google container
engine called client eastward which
handles that requests make sure that
it's connected fries right bridge and
routes that message via a Redis instant
running on compute engine towards
another container which actually handles
the connection towards bridges the new
way we're doing this now is of a service
we call Freddie Mercury which actually
maintains a permanent open web socket
towards every single bridge in the world
and we do that to get latency as low as
possible it's always a connection ready
to take that command so you can turn on
the lights immediately it arrives there
and it's pushed down this WebSocket
towards the bridge inside the home the
bridge takes that and sends out a ZigBee
wireless message towards the lights in
the home and they turn off and all of
this happens in less than 300
milliseconds and happens millions of
times every day and that's how we turn
on the light bulb in 2017 and how we're
using blue cloud platform to Duritz
thank you thank you thank you George
Freddie Mercury that was a fantastic
story and this this these halls are
filled with customers and users today
they're leveraging Google cloud platform
for all kinds of exciting use cases and
I encourage you to share those stories
with other folks in returns here and
perhaps tomorrow or next year you'll be
on stage here with us so as I mentioned
before data is really key to success in
today's environment and Google has
really been at the forefront of this
kind of of attitude is you may have
heard Google's motto is to organize
world's data and essentially provide
their very high-level value to that data
we really mean that the heart Google's
culture is fanatically data-driven all
decisions are made through data-driven
argument and debate it can be actually a
little bit maddening sometimes but so
that this embrace of data is is really
key
again and so in order to to really take
the first steps let's a convinced you
you should probably start by taking care
of your operational your transactional
your application database layer and so
I'm here to talk about Klotz banner
which is just an incredible technology
it's it's it's amazing so traditionally
when building an operational application
database you had a binary choice
you were probably going to try to use a
traditional relational database which
has rich sequel semantics strong
consistency transactions but sadly a
relational database doesn't really scale
right you may hit some limits at which
point you perhaps will choose to shard
your databases which increases
complexity of operations multiple times
over and so the new the no sequel
movement was born or it traded away some
of the really nice benefits of
relational databases in exchange for
horizontal scaling and in exchange for
availability so you don't get really
nice sequel you may not get strong
consistency you may not get you might
not get transactions but you get scale
right so and Google recognized this of
course that this is kind of an
inefficient this binary choice we can do
better than this so cloud spanner was
born and at Google cloud spanners and
been in production for the past five or
six years or so running hundreds of
applications including some of our
biggest ones like Adwords so what is
cloud spanner it is world's first
horizontally scalable relational
database cloud spanner provides strong
consistency of transactions provides
rich standard sequel dialect and as a
has a very high level of abstraction
it's a fully managed service so that
you're not inundated with tasks like
setting up infrastructure and
identifying how to shard keys and so on
and so forth so spanner lets you focus
on what's important to your business and
again of course spanner is replicated
regionally and potentially even globally
right which is a very new novel concept
and of course spanner is battle-tested
with Google as I mentioned before so how
does spanner achieve this it sounds too
good to be true really there are two
components that I should talk about here
the first one is true time true tom is a
software and hardware servers inside of
Google that allows you to retrieve
accurate time stamps within a non zero
error bound true time allows us to
serialize transactions with strong
levels of confidence and that's really
the key to providing strong consistency
of transactions that are spread
geographically the second one is a very
unique feature of Google that some folks
before me may have mentioned and that's
Google's private network Google manages
your packets between data centers it
will take a packet from data center a to
data center B and again very high levels
of confidence that those packets will
make it there now those packets your
data never leaves Google Network and
we're able to really understand when you
know any kind of degradation happens
there and so the other way to look at it
is you might have heard of the cap
theorem of distributed systems the cap
theorem basically says that there are
there are three aspects to distributed
systems there's the consistency
availability and partitions and what
they mean by partitions is network
partitions which is just a nice way of
saying that bad things happen to
networks and that's really what the cap
theorem says is bad things happen to
networks so you have to choose between C
and a between consistency and
availability googles private network
allows us to minimize the key down to
seconds a year so the in reality in
theory we still have the P to worry
about but in practice the P is minimized
so much that it's not a concern so now
you can have both consistency and
availability right and that's what
spanner gives you and now I have Robert
who has probably the best job at Google
because he gets to play around with
tools like spanner every single day is
gonna give us a live download spanner hi
thanks Tina so all that said it sounds
like it's going to be a lot of work to
get spanner
for running now well we've tried to
reduce that to something very very
simple so on this first screen and I'll
zoom in a little bit we're actually
going to create an instance so let's
call it next Amsterdam and we're going
to choose here a number of nodes so
these are nodes of spanner and we're
going to go for 42 obviously and that's
it I'm in the process now and I've just
created created and deployed my spanner
instance with 42 nodes
okay that's really cool but let's
actually see a use case and see what
happens okay so we're gonna switch to
our next tab so what's going on here we
have an application it's being deployed
in three regions so we have Europe Asia
and North America and basically we've
got about billion tickets to sell and we
have 800,000 events and what we're
trying to do globally is sell these
tickets to the customers who want to buy
them
and obviously we don't want to sell the
same ticket to more than one person so
having a horizontal available database
is going to be really useful
so we've deployed spanner in all those
three regions as well and for this demo
we've actually deployed kubernetes
clusters there as well to actually
simulate this interaction and as you can
see at the moment we've sold about 10
million tickets and we're about 600,000
tickets per minute so let's dive down a
bit
this is the schema that we're using for
our ticket service and I think there are
two things to notice here one it looks
like your everyday relational normalized
database schema which is great everyone
can understand it you can have a
conversation around it with your analyst
with your developers but let's look at
one of these tables here so the ticket
table is already containing 1.8 billion
rows and that's in one table that table
isn't sharded that's just one table that
you can look at and it doesn't matter if
you're looking at from America Europe or
Asia uses us for your all intents and
purposes you're looking at a local table
containing 1 billion rows
so the next thing I'm gonna do is pull
up a query and actually run a query
against spanner while why we're doing
all of this work so let me just go and
grab this query which I prepared so we
should have a query here for Amsterdam
selecting that okay
so I'm clearing the data why all that
other stuff is going on and there's one
thing I want you to notice about this
query if i zoom in that might help a bit
as well this is a pretty normal-looking
sequel query so something else that you
get with spanner normal plane sequel
interoperability so the next thing we're
going to do is add some more nodes to
our spanner incidents so you can imagine
all this is going on one of the things
that span a tree offers you is to make
changes to the schema real time which is
would give you that ability to actually
go and add new features to your your
system your application but what about
if your application actually needs more
power well it's as simple as zooming in
again editing the instance and saying
give me some more nodes and there we go
we've just got some more nodes this
spanner as with all of our Google Cloud
products is fully integrated is a fully
managed service as you've just seen I'm
not going in there and configuring
things and doing all kind of develop
stuff but what we've also done is made
sure it's connected with our monitoring
system the stack driver and I just want
to pay attention here to a few graphs so
one of the graphs this is this is the
period when we started loading this
initial data into spanner for this demo
and there are few graphs here you can
have a look at so these are the nodes
going up and down but this one here when
we started to load our data we were
going about 200 to 300 megabytes for a
second and we actually increased that to
get some more in to like 600 megabytes
per second of loading data into our
spanner instance and we're going to come
back to this and look what's happening
we're going to zoom in and America over
and look at the latency there we're
selling there about 200,000 tickets a
second a minute sorry so with that I'm
going to hand it back to Tina
that was spanner
[Applause]
wow what an amazing database just just a
fact alone that he was able to resize
the size of a spanner cluster so easily
it's transformative these types of
things to Google months and months to do
before spanner and so you can take
advantage of this today
spanner when GA roughly a month ago
almost to the date and again spanner
gives you the best of both worlds you
get the nice equal semantics you get
strong transactional layer of relational
databases but to get the scale
characteristics an availability of no
sequel databases so please encourage you
to take a look at spanner it's really
exciting now that we've taken care of
the application layer now that we have
our operational transactional database
up and running synced across the entire
world let's talk about how to get some
more value out of this data right
because you really want to understand
your customer you want to delight them
you want to custom tailor have the
custom tailor made experiences for each
individual customer and at the same time
you want to be identifying opportunities
potentially for for future exploration
and future innovation future iteration
so really the the tool that you uses
that Google uses internally and Google
customers use externally as well is a
query it quarries the product that I had
the pleasure of working on before coming
over onto my new team and the query is
essentially a server list fully managed
analytics data warehouse what do we mean
by that what we mean is that you never
have to touch Hardware again you never
have to resize your cluster you never
have to specify any kind of
configuration like RAM CPU and so forth
the query just works the core it has two
major components that you can think
about the first one is a sophisticated
exabyte scale storage engine that allows
you to move data into bigquery in
real-time and share datasets across your
organization or with your third parties
just the same way Google Docs allows you
to share information
besides storage is we have the execution
engine which allows you to execute
standard sequel at the speed of thought
gives your data scientist your data
engineers the analysts the power to see
inside of the data understand the shape
of the data so customers of course
prefer be querying for its price and
performance characteristics but their
most vocal about the operational
simplicity aspect of McQuarrie it really
is is a set and forget technology it's
really no ops
it requires no workloads to my manager
right you just use bigquery but of
course in order to use bigquery properly
just like any other database you need to
move data into bigquery which is
potentially not the most glorious
endeavor right ETL is hard and you know
it's kind of a requirements it means to
an end
so for that purpose if you have data
sets that reside inside of Google if
you're an AdWords user if you're a
double-click user
Google X premium and YouTube we're on
your behalf are able to move that data
automatically inside of bigquery so your
analysts can use any number of holistic
tools like sequel or Python to analyze
that data together or with datasets that
you own that you bring it to the query
as well and we'll be bringing in other
datasets into the query as well in the
future so our clients tell us there are
really three major ways to use Google
cloud platform to derive value for your
organization the first one I already
talked about is that this cloud native
data warehouse concept but the query
holds and it's really transformative
right this is changing how folks think
about data health folks think about
analyzing that in real time is sequel
the second one is management and Hadoop
and spark its 2017 it's been 11 years
since Hadoop first came around and
Hadoop is still very very hard to work
with right it's it's a big headache it's
not unusual for clients to tell me that
it takes six to nine months on-premise
for them to get more infrastructure to
get more story
or more compute capacity to increase the
size of their Hadoop clusters six to
nine months and at the same time once
you do have capacity sometimes I'm being
told that a runaway query can take down
the whole thing right then and there are
tools like your on resource manager that
allow you to to kind of break up the
resources but it still doesn't go far so
Google's Hadoop and spark service called
data proc allows you to spin up clusters
in seconds right the 98% offer
performance to get a cluster up and
running is about 60 seconds which is
incredible the third use case that I can
talk about is real-time analytics now
there's nothing wrong with with waiting
a day or two until you get analysis
integrated from into your your business
but there are use cases where you want
data analyzed in real time if it looks
huge is a great example of that right
you want now analytics on your
application as quickly as possible
so IOT gaming and clickstream three of
the examples that the where real-time
analytics becomes really useful now
we've taken care of the application
layer we know what the shape of the data
looks like but to truly get the most out
of your data you can start embracing
machine learning and AI and this is a
relatively new concept of course
actually it's a relatively old concept
but because of the advancements in
computing it's become a practical
concept these days and Google is really
attempted to democratize the concept of
the AI through our investments in
tensorflow which is very popular
open-source project through our
acquisition of Kaggle which is a
community of AI and machine learning
experts and of course through our fully
managed machine learning service cloud
ml engine cloud machine learning engine
allows you to train your custom pencil
flow models on your data using our CPUs
and GPUs we abstract away the complexity
of running a distributed tensorflow
cluster so you can just focus on the
really difficult problem which is
machine learning and once you have the
train data set once you have your model
in place you can take that model for
inference for future
on premise auto mobile device or on to
Google cloud of course we we all know
that a is hard machine learning is very
very hard right not everybody's ready
there's not a whole lot of talent that
really expertly knows machine learning
to that extent we are externalizing and
we have externalized a number of pre
trained machine learning models that
power the same tools that Google uses
today for example google photos or
google image search or Google Safe
Search or actually Google Translate
right so this these same models are
being externalized for you to use so
that any engineer that knows how to work
with a REST API or Java Script can build
an application that can talk that can be
machine learning driven AI driven and
can talk to the real world I'm going to
talk about a couple of these
the first one is vision API it's been
available over the past year or so and
they've actually annotated over a
billion and a half images by now a
couple of use cases the first one is a
real estate companies often take images
of you know real estate properties and
facility and extract metadata the
facilitates transactions the second one
is social media companies are able to
leverage the vision API to filter out
you know informative content there are
two in the vision API just like all of
our services tends to iterate and
innovate right you kind of get better
and better features more and more
features as time goes on it's an
intrinsic quality of Google Cloud two of
the most recent features features that
vision API has introduced our advanced
OCR and a implementation of knowledge
graph method metadata advanced OCR or
optical character recognition allows you
to visualize or to translate physical
documents like legal documents or
medical documents translate them into
text extract the text away from that and
knowledge graph metadata essentially
social what Google did is we tied
together the vision API with our
knowledge graph metadata database so
the same the same metadata database that
powers Google Images for example you are
able to use today right so it's just
enrichment of this vision API
with Google's internal tools the next
one is actually just just fascinating as
well and you guys will get to take a
look at what what this looks like in
alive the vast majority of data that's
being generated today in the world is
really videos hundreds of terabytes
every single hour and it's very hard to
work with videos right you can't run
sequel on it you can't really store it
in a database so what if you could
extract valuable information about your
videos and video content in a very
simple manner and I have ly to
demonstrate that for us thank you - you
know actually I'm very excited today to
demonstrate the video and challenges API
because it's really one of my favorite
Google cloud products that's online so I
will explain to you first what it is it
is machine learning it's a pre trained
model that we as developers can use
through a REST API so you don't need to
be a data scientist or build a hard
stuff it's already there and once you
connect to this REST API machine
learning can understand the context of
the video and also detect first screen
pristine what's in the scene and we'll
label it and also we'll give you back on
which timestamp that happened and I can
show you that in an in a real demo I
have a video of actually it was a video
of YouTube searches in 2016 where all
things what happened in in the air to
take 16 so I'm scrolling through it and
you see like lots of people things of
politics and and sports and if you
scroll down you can see the video
intelligence API detected all these
keywords so everything that's happening
in this video now imagine that you have
a company you no longer need to watch a
full video to label or categorize a
video but you can let the computer
basically do that and also see on what
time that happens so if we can see here
apparently in this scene there is a dog
and here's a construction worker I think
that's amazing let's think about another
use case and I think that's probably a
real life let's say you have a company
and you have like petabytes of video
files on your website and you need to
find a certain scene to highlight that
so let's let's try that out since it's
officially summer today I thought like
maybe it's nice to look for the word
beaches and see if we have videos that
contain a beach and now you see these
are all videos would be just and you can
see you see also on which time frame
added the beach area did that happen so
if I could click here then I mean they
may refresh the page then you should see
the in detail so they were aware that
where the beach was really happening
and that is actually pretty amazing
because like if I would blink my eye I
probably would have missed it so this is
really great
now I hand it over back to Tino
thanks Lee Lee and Robert our customer
engineers here in Amsterdam and it's
it's a I've said this before customer
engineers ago will probably have the
coolest jobs they get to they get to use
all the cool toys and they get to talk
to customers and solve your real-world
problems and they get to demo stuff they
do video intelligence API is really
indicative of what Google Chrome is
trying to do in general right it's video
intelligence API is the results of
intense investments in AI and data
science and lots of research inside of
Google that makes its way into your
hands as a customer but also through a
very very high level of abstraction so
that your everyday analysts and your
everyday engineers can leverage a simple
API to to provide really valuable use
cases and to have your applications
actually interact with the world in the
same way in humans - this is fascinating
right this this this new reality of the
belivet and so to kind of wrap up I'd
like to kind of give you a little bit of
a thought today you you must embrace
data you must embrace the fact that data
drives all decisions makings in the
world right and so in order to to really
propel yourself and to innovate further
you need to take care of all the layers
of data management all the way from the
application database to the analytics
database and then potentially even to AI
a machine learning and with that I'd
like to introduce bill who is actually a
head of customer engineers here for amia
and Bill is going to talk about how
Google allows it to collaborate thanks
Danielle appreciate it
selectee no said my name is bill HIPAA
Myer and I recently have moved from
California or Mountain View office to
London so that we could build out our
customer engineering organization across
amia we're making big investments in our
go to market forces and it's it's Diane
greens belief and my belief as well that
we're going to engage best with you when
we go engineer to engineer when we have
people that have knowledge about
products capabilities that we provide
can apply those to problems that you
have and show you the art of the
possible of what's going next the
problem is and here's something that we
really have to pause on for a minute is
that we're all trying to drive these
transformation outcomes right new
methods new ways to approach problems
new markets new customer solutions new
ways to interact with partners and the
ecosystem which which we work that's
great that comes from what that
innovation is really a result of
transformative ideas that we create and
think about in the workplace with these
same partners those transformative ideas
are built on creativity creativity is
the crucible which allows us to come up
with new ideas which lead to
transformation but the question I have
for you as an audience today as you sit
there is what is the catalyst for that
creative process right what is it that
gets people to be able to come up with
new ideas and actually think of a
different approach a different way a
different method to be able to affect an
outcome that does it I submit to you
that that is engagement when two or more
people get together they lock themselves
in a room in a conference place or
they're in a Google Doc working together
in real-time they're starting to create
think and reason together and what
happens and you all have this experience
is you begin to synthesize new ideas
from existing components existing facts
and your observations about the world
around you and that's what we are doing
in Google cloud in our collaboration
suite we've had great success
introducing G suite just over just
around ten years ago I joined Google
around 2007 so I've been coming
make up on my 10 year anniversary and I
began the Google journey in the
collaboration space and what Google
brings a new product to market our
thinking is how do we impact over a
billion people how do we solve problems
that no one else is addressing and how
do we bring something that is unique to
the flavor that only Google can do and
this is what we believe we have
delivered in the context of G suite
there's a problem though we have a great
suite of capabilities right from
real-time collaboration to meetings to
Google Drive to all these great products
that service that collaborative effort
and allow you to connect and create
together but what we've recognized is
that that's not enough it's not enough
to just be able to create and to be able
to work together in real-time we have to
take the power of machine learning and
apply it to everything we're doing
because what's happening in the
workplace today is there are obstacles
to my creating the next big idea and
those obstacles are number one I don't
have enough time I've got to create
space for creativity right I've got to
have a set of tools that will optimize
my day optimize the way I work find the
things I need when I need them so that I
can create more room for creativity and
more room for collaboration the second
thing that I have to do is I have to
lift my game right I have to be able to
work smarter and work more intelligently
and I have to do so using best practices
of those that are around the experts
within the field in my sphere of
influence and outside of my sphere of
influence so I've got to have
intelligent solutions that allow me to
do that the third thing is the tools
have to be built fundamentally for teams
not for individuals right we need to
have tools that actually get us to
engage to get that catalyst working to
create to transform and then reap the
rewards of that and then finally the
fourth point which is important is that
I've got to have tools that integrate
with the back office integrate with the
workflow and integrate with the other
components that I use on a daily basis
like the ERP system and the CRM system
so what I want to do over the next
couple of minutes is I'm going to give
you a glimpse into some
the things that we're doing in Google to
help us solve those four problems that
will allow us to arrive at the
transformations we need and depend and
demand in today's world let's start a
little bit with artificial intelligence
alright as you know Google has been
working in this field for a long long
time and many of you experienced the
benefit of type-ahead which is built
under the AI algorithm that examines all
of the different words that people are
typing in in different languages to
provide useful suggestions to be able to
allow you to find information that's a
great example of time savings all right
when you use type-ahead as an example
you're finding results faster you're
finding more relevant results and you're
getting to the information you need
quickly to get that but that can be
integrated into everything we do so
let's take a look at what we're doing in
artificial intelligence right we're
working on systems integrated into the G
suite product to allow you to recover
lost time improve your team
effectiveness and cover uncover big
ideas and let's begin with Drive so the
first innovation that I want to talk to
you about about is Drive quick access
Drive quick access is a mecca of
mechanism by which we are looking at
your schedule we are looking at the
interactions you have in chat we are
examining the things that you're doing
is you collaborate with the people
around you and then we're surfacing the
content that you need at a fingertip
when you need it it turns out that if
you measure it over 40% of the documents
that you need are now being accessed
directly from this new capability in
Drive called quick access so when I open
up drive now and I look at the top bar
yes there's a search bar up there and
yes it's very useful to be able to do
type-ahead searches to find information
but more importantly the documents that
I'm most likely to need are presented to
me based on the context and algorithms
that we're building in and using an
artificial intelligence to surface this
content so that's an example of giving
you more time it might be in
microseconds or seconds but if you add
that up what that's going to do across
the suite is going to allow you to have
more productive thought time more
active opportunities to engage with
others the second innovation that we
brought to market is the Explorer
functionality within sheets I don't know
about you but I'm pretty good with
spreadsheets but I am NOT the guru that
can write a very very complex statement
that uses all of the complexities of the
spreadsheet language to be able to
search and find things in cells here's
an example of a question right what is
the most frequent garment type from the
point-of-sale data that I've been
collecting over the last 10 years
analyzed by geography by location by
language by segment of the market right
when you ask that question how many of
you can immediately write the formula
that's going to look at potentially
terabytes of information and be able to
pull that information up and put it in
the graph in a matter of seconds it's
not an easy thing to do right the best
people that know spreadsheets that work
with this data do it well but the
average person struggles a bit with that
with that formula so you can go into
Explorer right now and you can use the
natural language query processing and
you can simply ask that question right
what is the most frequent garment type
and you can add things to it by
geography etc and that I talked about
earlier and we will actually not only
show you the results of that query but
will also write the formula for you so
if you want to take that formula and
drop it into the cells that that apply
and do the summarization you'll get that
immediately and now the next person that
wants to come into that sheet and
examine that content they do not have to
be able to write the formula they don't
even have to know to ask the question
the information is available to them
processed and ready to go so being able
to raise your game raise your ability to
interact with the data move to a natural
language processing capability is one of
the outcomes that you get from the
application of AI and machine learning
into in this case sheets but how do we
enhance your ability to collaborate
together well there are a number of
things that we're releasing in the
product now and have recently released
to be able to get people to be able to
engage
more proactively engaged in real-time
we've talked about Google Drive and
Google Drive is going to be the next we
predict by the end of this year that
Google Drive will be over the billion
the billion monthly active user point
and when we measure an active user that
is not a registered user that is someone
who is a seven-day active somebody who's
used the product in the context of the
last seven days so finding your
information and placing your documents
and drive we think is good but that
again is not enough so this year we
announced team drive team drive is that
creative space where I can declaratively
create the space I can add the
colleagues and people that are working
with me on a particular project and then
now what happens is all the content that
we click that we create all the content
that we interact with and all the stuff
that we store belongs to the team not
the individual this solves a number of
problems the first problem it solves is
what happens when a new team member
comes in to your existing file structure
system you have to go through and do all
the shares required to be able to bring
that person into the project with team
drive we eliminate that need as soon as
a new person joins the team they
automatically have access to the content
that they need to be able to collaborate
with you and drive the project forward
the other problem we're solving with
Team Drive is what do you do with the
content when someone leaves the
organization if using a traditional file
store NetApp filer and even a cloud
storage solution from another vendor you
have to go through this process of
trying to figure out when that person
leaves and I'm going to eliminate their
idea what is the disposition of their
content who do I give it to do I give it
to their manager do I divide it up among
the team members and how do I go about
and make sure that every single document
is appropriately disposed of and placed
in its proper place with Team Drive you
don't have to worry about that when
someone leaves the team or leaves the
organization the content doesn't belong
to the individual the content belongs to
the team belongs to the organization
it's a better place to collaborate it's
more effective
we're also doing a lot in chat chat is a
great tool that has traditionally done
one-to-one occasionally you'll get into
a group chat but you're not really
thinking about in terms of a team
experience where I have a repository of
interactions that I'm having with the
team and I have continuity of the
conversations through time so we are
bringing to market a new capability
which is hangouts chat and hangouts chat
is designed to solve that problem of
being able to give you a team and
organizational view of the conversations
that you have the informal conversations
you have to be able to move work forward
we also are greatly enhancing our our
hangout product and relabeling that as
hangouts meet in hangouts if you've used
hangouts you can see what a great tool
it is to be able to immediately connect
to a number of people both in and
outside of the organization to be able
to have a video collaboration experience
but what you need to make it an
enterprise capability is you need things
like the ability to record a meeting
right how many times do you do a team
meeting or maybe an all-hands call where
you're giving out important content but
there are people that are on holiday
there are people that are sick there are
people that have conflicting meetings
and can't make it that you need to be
able to have the ability to record
content you also need to make it
seamless for people to be able to get
into the meeting regardless of what
device or what location they are and
what the power of their network is so
why shouldn't every single meeting have
a bridge a phone bridge where if I'm in
a low bandwidth location and it's not
possible for me to get the best out of
my IP network why shouldn't I
automatically offer you the ability to
dial into the bridge and and just click
a button and be able to be connected
into that why can't I connect other
people without having to do the click
the type in the conference bridge number
type in the leader code you know go
through all the sequence of numbers
realizing that you miss type the fifth
digit of a 15 digit number and all the
hassle associated with joining a meeting
that way it should be one click it
should be automatic it should be
accessible from mobile from desktop and
from any location that you're in so
we're doing a lot in hangouts meet to be
able to
bring the power of hangouts to the
enterprise you also need to increase the
number of people that are interacting so
we're going and increasing that number
every single year to be able to make it
so you can have large meetings as well
as intimates small meetings so that's
what we're doing an example of some of
the things we're doing around team
collaboration and getting people
together what about that fourth place
what about the integration right of your
workplace to where when I'm in email and
I need to be able to get to another
application I can do it quickly what
about actually building applications
that use these capabilities to be able
to provide new services to your
organization and to your customers and
partners well the traditional
development strategy right is great if
you're a computer science software
engineer so if you're a Python
programmer or a Java programmer and you
want to go in and write a complex system
and use all the power that the cloud has
to offer right that's that's wonderful
but what if you're a power business user
right where is the market left you in
terms of building a dynamic and active
application built on top of this
infrastructure and built on platform as
a service to where I can build a simple
application as a power user deploy that
into Google Cloud and have it
automatically scale to billions of users
should I need that capability well I'd
like to introduce you to a platform and
a development capability called app
maker and I think the best way to
introduce you to that is to show you a
video of people that are using it today
and the experience that they've had
let's roll the video
[Music]
you're on Google and you're enjoying the
collaboration products mail calendar
contacts however you also have this need
for business process to be automated our
agency they don't have the money to do a
full-fledged app they just need
something simple that makes their life
easier right now we have the blue form
because it the blue sheet of paper
the Wyoming flexible benefits enrollment
plan you're filling it out and signing
it and then they have to data entry all
that back in ten thousand people a lot
of blue trees we were able to make this
an app maker we showed it to our HR
department and they were so excited
honestly at first I was very skeptical
it just seemed too easy like oh yeah I
dragon drop a couple little things what
do I care I'm a real developer I don't
use these little gadgets but as I got to
use the tool more I was like wow you
know this really can do some pretty cool
stuff I was able to develop a relatively
sophisticated app for login monitoring
from ideation all the way through the
final delivered app to our
administrators for them to use was five
weeks and that's just unheard of in any
other kind of product lifecycle boy app
maker because not everyone is me I
really like working deep down in the
code working low-level the great thing
about app maker is you don't need to
have that deep down knowledge people are
able to make these really snazzy looking
applications that can be used by an
entire company I never pictured myself
developing anything at maker is an
insanely awesome way to solve a small
problem maker makes my job easier
because I I don't need multiple tools I
can just develop it directly on top
maker
one word to describe app maker simple
quick flexible versatile and pound it
one word to describe app maker
game-changer so app maker creates the
development environment which which can
build simple applications that scale to
billions of users on top of Google
infrastructure and it sits on top of a
rich set of api's so not only can you
build applications but you can also
build applications that integrate your
collaboration environment so we've
announced the spreadsheets API and the
slides API as examples of api's that
allow you to start to programmatically
create content programmatically
manipulate slide decks and do those
types of things so that you can actually
integrate these types of workflows in
addition to that we've also introduced
the concept of gmail add-ons right when
you're working in the context of your
email inbox that is where I get a lot of
my to Do's
that is where I'm actually blunting to
do most of my work so in the morning I
might get for example a customer
complaint or an issue or a concern or
some sort of escalation in that might be
a trouble ticket right I don't want to
have to leave the context of my email go
in and log into the trouble ticketing
system look up the reference to the
trouble find out what's been done on
that ticket in the last 24 hours
contact the engineer that's working on
it to get information why can't I simply
integrate that experience where I can
click on the ticket number and through
Gmail add-ons surface the application
directly in the context of the work I'm
doing go and look the information up I
need grab some of the information stick
it back into the email reply and reduce
the time it takes to effectively resolve
a customer concern if you add those up
over the course of your year you begin
to free up you begin to work more
collaboratively you're able to actually
leverage the power of a collaboration
solution that was built for teams so we
have a bunch of Technology here in the
collaboration suite
we think it's differentiated and we
think it will help you do what we think
our collaboration suite uniquely helps
you
achieve the transformative outcomes
you're doing based on coming up with big
ideas which is fostered by a creative
environment which is catalyzed by your
ability to engage with others so without
what I'd like to do is take you to the
final round we're now in the u.s. we
would say in baseball we're heading
around third and we're going home now
and to do that I would like to bring up
Andre who is going to talk a little bit
about what we're doing to maintain an
open environment so that you can make
sure that when you build things on our
platform that they're going to run in
other places and that you're gonna work
in an open platform so Andre thank you
wow what an audience you can't believe
how excited I am about this absolutely
fantastic how are you guys doing how is
everybody doing us also in the breakout
room so we have overflow rooms we I just
looked and we have over 14 almost 1,500
folks in the venue now you can hear the
bus from the partner room to me this is
absolutely absolutely exciting four
years ago I started in Google and it
went like this hey Andre just here you
have the Benelux the Nordics north of
europe and just go and build the
Beasties for cloud platforms so that's
that's where I started and it was
absolutely an amazing journey many many
unknown faces in the public working with
Phillips was really amazing winning
Spotify was absolutely fantastic cool
blue there's so many customers I'm
really privileged to have seen that one
of the reasons that I joined Google is
Google's vision on openness and today I
would like to speak with you especially
about that and there's three pieces I
would like to touch here one Google's
support for open source and how Google
believes that it will speed up
innovation second is how we are open to
other technologies and third flexibility
in pricing and how Google believes that
pricing should be flexible and driveways
down to zero
imagine that you are in a new market and
you are in a new market one way or the
other
everybody here right the next big thing
and your competition has a three year or
multi-year head start in front of you
what are you going to do how are you
going to compete you might think of
Google cloud maybe know if this happened
to Linux and 20 years ago the internet
that was the next big thing and honest
Linux was not such a great platform in
those days Yahoo was really big they had
their own operating system so large a
super super popular and we all know what
happened UNIX became the platform of the
internet right because it's open now
really because it's open because it is
had a higher rate of innovation google
has a long-standing history of
supporting open source systems Linux
gets C++ many of those that is all
anecdotal right so let's look at some
numbers over 280,000 commits from
google.com accounts in one year 2016 so
if you do the math at 700 per day what's
super amazing right
15,000 projects that that Google is
supporting over 2,500 long during
projects going on and there's another
piece here open source a steering a
community of high collaboration and of
high innovation and high speeds of
innovation let's look at an example wood
started out as Googlers adding
functionality to the C kernel of Linux
to just manage resources like CPU sets
and other resources grew into what we
know now as containers micro services
and twelve years later now companies
around the world people around the world
are speeding up application development
and DevOps through through containers
and at Google they use that of course
also and containers in itself look great
containers also need to be managed to
need to be orchestrated right so in
Google we have this humongous robot that
we lovingly call Bork and I know we make
the we make the jokes the resistance is
futile right and Bork we made a super
bold decision Bork by the way in Google
is is orchestrating over 2 billion micro
services today so that is it is quite a
humongous robot have you made a bold
decision what we did is the open-source
Borg and they gave the code and the
management of IP to the Linux Foundation
and their cue Benitez was born and look
at what happened cue Benitez this is the
cue Benitez project four thousand
projects four hundred years of effort
went into Cuba need is four hundred
years in in the last three years where
you think what does it matter well at
Google we believe that freedom matters
most you write your code once and then
you decide where I'm going to run it on
premise in my private cloud maybe maybe
multiple clouds maybe on the Google
cloud so in essence it means at any
point you can leave and it also means at
any point you can join now this is true
for the stuff that you're orchestrating
with Cuba neat is it also counts for
Cuban eases instances itself you can run
it with us you can also use our manage
cuban eaters right and it also is true
for well take tensorflow
the open source dead right so you can
run it on premise you can run it in the
cloud but you also can use our our
managed services for machine learning
cloud amel right oh you can even go
higher and use our trained datasets like
we saw beautiful video beautiful demos
of the video api and all that stuff from
li the second part i would like to touch
is how open we are for other
technologies how many of you in the
audience are in financial services on
touching
touching Kabul somewhere yeah
so it happens right so anything that you
can run in a container now you can point
at with with appengine flex and you can
pull it in and run it inside so next to
appengine how we support our platforms
like a Python and go and all the seven
you can now also add all your code and
put it in and use appengine flex with us
absolutely awesome another piece I'm
proud of that is our continuous support
for Windows and not to just be an OK
platform to run Windows code on now we
really want to be the best
high-performing place for Windows to be
so you really that people really like to
be bring their code bring Visual Studio
for example facial studio has an SDK to
seamlessly integrate your IDE integrated
development environment into our cloud
we support all versions of sequel server
web Edition standard edition and we also
announced support for Enterprise Edition
we have numerous support for no a
pre-installed images for Windows Server
all those versions right and also now in
better weather support for dotnet core
so we touched open source now we believe
that it's speeding up our innovation we
touched being open for other code and
other other technologies now I would
like to look at pricing and flexibility
of pricing when I speak with people
about their bill their spend on clouds
they're usually not that happy and that
is not because of cost usually that is
because of waste that is fixed viens per
hour billing and then having three years
leases of those fixed VMs and I got told
somewhere that cloud is about flexible
resource and elastic resource capacity
and all that stuff so Google believes
that pricing should be flexible and that
you should have as minimum waste
and 2014 in March it was in 2014 Google
committed itself ourself to follow
Moore's law you remember every year
doubling of compute power so we're
disturb the margin go in the 6% but the
cloud that's going down and then we
started driving the price down keep
stick with Moore's law and we started
innovating an example of this innovation
is automatic sustained usage discount
and honestly you cannot screw this up
really you run a VM and after the first
quarter of the month discount starts
kicking in automatically right until 30
percent in the end of the month
is pretty unique another example is how
we have custom machine types if you have
a 24 core 60 gigabyte ram instance if
you need that we believe that you should
be able to run that and this reminds me
vividly of after all the work on
technology and vision with Spotify that
we did I know them very well we had a
commercial negotiations and they had
clusters thousands of nodes for had to
and they had exotic instances and we
were trying to create a business case
because the strategy was we first lifts
and shifts and then we peel up that that
Hadoop cluster and get on the higher
level service right like Sebastian said
in the beginning and we could not close
the business case either too much CPU or
coarse and or too much memory and then
we did something special
Tommy cursor was there I said hey let me
call some folks in the dungeon and we
create a special SKU for them a special
instance type and we did and there we
could compare apples to apples and now
we have available for you custom machine
types so you can compare apples to
apples in your environment right and if
you don't know what the right size is we
are monitoring your infrastructure so we
will recommend you we won't do music
recommendations to you but this is more
like a machine-type recommendation okay
so you'll get it right and usually in
the beginning through developments your
requirements on your environment is very
very different than in the times of your
operations later on so things change
with you if you are planning your
infrastructure in the development phase
you might go off of the line and you
generate waste and then per our main
building so we have Trouper our building
11 mean it's easy 11 minutes right so
you don't have to put an alarm clock on
the top of the hour and at the start and
stop your clusters there now all these
elements are working as a tendon right
whether it's sustained uses discount at
the driving up prices down or custom
machine types the old work is a tendon
and we know we have seen that average
prices average bills are going you can
be cheaper like 60% and now nobody's
ever - you're right I would like to
close with one open source Google
believes that that's the way to speed up
innovation for Google - we are open very
open to other technologies a great home
for the technologies and three we are we
have a flexible pricing so that we can
drive you can drive ways to zero and now
I would like to welcome to stage Misha
Brown fell of world press and here's a
great example of bringing code and
dotnet to to our platform and Misha the
floor is yours thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Andre thank you
Google next 17 there is people leaving
and I just learned from the organization
here that the breakout sessions will
start as of 11:30 after this meeting so
please all stay here so you can learn on
all these wonderful presentations so my
name is Misha braunfels I am director of
contests that will press photo and you
probably you know will press photo for
the word press photo of the year and the
whoopers photo is the most important
photo journalistic contest in the world
actually we say these times we are the
most important visual journalism contest
in the world and I want to explain why
[Applause]
so I'm going to talk about exchanging
visual information and exchanging visual
information we'll start with a lovely
video made by George Beckley and this is
about 165 years listen up 165 years of
front pages of the New York Times
so Hugh sees ministrations which took
about 50 years and then somewhere after
more than like a hundred years no
somewhere in the beginning of the 20th
century they started to have pictures as
well and as of the 1950s regular
pictures on the front page
and this this is the 90s colored
pictures of the front page of the most
important newspaper in the world as they
say so what actually wanted to discuss
with you guys is exiting to go back like
20 years ago we are an organization we
were started in 1955 and which is about
still about still photography and
somewhere here in 1998 digital came in
so we accepted digital photographs in
our contest it's not even 20 years ago
and you see what happened blue is
digital so within five years slides were
very expensive they left prints were out
quite soon as well as they were quite
expensive as well
digital took over so what happened with
the digital so digital took off
completely we receives more entries and
people from all over the world were able
to enter their entries to a press
further and please be aware the figures
are not as high but that's because what
best photo is a contest for professional
photographers so it's not for everyone
so these things happen
Digital comes in everyone is taking
pictures with this but it really took a
while before in this professional
contest a picture taken with a mobile
camera or with a mobile phone did win
this is a picture from two years ago but
also other mediums actually were used
creating visual storytelling Google
Streetview
won in 2011 with the story in the world
press photo of the year the story is
called a series of unfortunate events
and it was a really really great story
you can see it on our on our website so
people were using different stuff
digitally to actually create visual
storytelling
and we are aware of that I will press
photo so as I said before I am the
director of contests so in 1955 we
started out with the photo contest and
since 2011 we have a digital
storytelling contest since we are aware
at our organization that visual stories
are produced in a different way and are
consumed in a different way so it's not
only stills anymore
here on D we have video and we have
interactive stories visual storytelling
[Music]
journalistic visual tour is telling
using different tools to actually you
know tell the story which need to be
tilt to the public this is actually a
touchscreen which is traveling together
with our exhibition to about 100
locations worldwide to actually show
what is happening in the world of visual
journalism talking about producing and
consuming visual stories snapchat 1.8
million snaps per minute whose average
snapchat here you're told
YouTube 4.1 million videos viewed per
minute which is like 6 billion a day the
snapchats in the end is like two and a
half billion snaps transferred per day
it's misses and you know I need to tell
you with these things talking about who
is producing this visual storytelling
it's not me who is doing this this is my
niece
see he's 12 and since this is how she's
communicating with me after I told her I
was actually coming over and see that
well maybe this is a funny picture there
is a total new generation growing up
with communicating with visuals so we
are aware of this as an organization and
we want to change and this is a picture
from 2013 this is the world press photo
of the year 2000
13 it's made by Johnston Meyer and what
we find out you know we are learning on
this visual storytelling and what we
really want is you know we want to keep
up with the speed you know we want to
inform the people so actually what we
did is we are talking to creators and
that they actually you know can use the
tools they love and are very effective
so we teamed up with cue 42 and we
created the bigger picture and these
guys from q42 our longtime dotnet
experts and they helped us with creating
this amazing project which I will show
you in a minute around exploring photos
and exploring context data journalism
using a picture as an entry point for
data journalism since we want to reach
out to this worldwide audience and we're
using Google Cloud for this so I'm
actually wanna I'm finishing my
presentation with a thing how we're
gonna explore the context and expose
data journalism on this picture
so what we think that we'll press photo
is we think it is really important to
tell the story so this is actually you
know the saying a picture says more than
a thousand words of course but a lot of
ones and a lot of zeroes can actually
tell you much more about this picture so
you know who are these people these
people are African migrants on the shore
in Djibouti City they trying to catch
cell signals from neighboring Somalia
since they want to get in touch with
their relatives before transferring the
red sea so that's these people so this
is the entry point but you know we want
to know who are these people so we
actually wanna explore the mobile owner
or the mobile phone ownership which they
have and which is quite low for refugees
but it's really important to have a
mobile phone for refugees what are these
barriers for you know to connectivity
for these refugees when they actually
travel or when they actually are
migrating
this connectivity for these migrants is
critical in the end since they need to
communicate with friends and they need
to communicate with others about where
they actually going and how they can go
there and how they can reach better
places so then so to use it for
navigations and for directions you know
to get to the next destination quicker
and hopefully safe to secure safe routes
and it's also resilience because you
know the people who are you know the
migrants who are actually like migrating
who actually are able to keep in touch
with their family for them it's actually
you know they have like the best way
actually to succeed in the end in the
end this connectivity empowers so it's
vital to empower refugees and to educate
themselves and for earning a livelihood
in this refugee sites
so for us let's we'll press photo it is
really important not only to show this
picture but also to tell the story
behind which we want to share with you
and with the public all over so thank
you Google Cloud for making that
possible thank you thank you very much
I don't have any more slides just to
close this morning in 10 seconds first
of all thank you very much for all the
speakers thank you very much for the
customers
it's always very inspiring to have true
stories I mean the technology school is
great it's powerful but at the end of
the day it's about solving business
issues and it's really about erring from
our customers so we had great customer
this morning if you want to extend the
experience the customer experience go to
youtube I mean go to youtube type next
Google next and you'll see a lot a lot
of different customer stories in each
and every single industry so this is
great because at the end of the day it's
really about you bringing your ideas
every day every day we're hosting
companies actually everybody's coming
with new ideas and they are telling us
we started the cloud journey not
necessarily with Google few years but
now with everything Google is doing the
cool technology is the machine learning
artificial intelligence and there are
narratives and so on you clearly we
clearly do a lot of things that we
couldn't do actually with the the first
partners we started the journey you know
it's not a one player journey it's a
multiplayer journey
and again we are really really here to
get challenged and share the technology
and start working with you on the
migration having said that this is the
end of the morning we are little bit
late so we are going to start sharp
really sharp in ten minutes of the
breakout session so thank you very much
and have a great day
[Applause]
[Music]